Bethlehem is widely celebrated as the
birthplace of Jesus droves of pilgrims
and Taurus visit the Palestinian City in
the West Bank to see The Grotto that
Believers Revere as the spot where Jesus
was born but one Israeli archaeologist
thinks everyone's got it wrong and he's
not alone his team has spent years
collecting artifacts in another
Bethlehem that's in Israel's Galilee
it's just down the road from the ancient
city of Nazareth
he says his findings prove that Joseph
and a heavily pregnant Mary walked just
seven kilometers not 150 to the manger
where the Christian Messiah was born
it's a well-known tale of a young family
in need of a boy whose birth began the
Christian narrative and founded an
entirely new religion
Joseph and the heavily pregnant Mary
travel from their home in Nazareth to
the city of Bethlehem near Jerusalem or
so the story goes but not everyone
agrees on the details
what are the chances that a nine month
pregnant woman would ride on a donkey
from Nazareth to to Bethlehem Judea
archaeologist aviram oshri spent 11
years Excavating another Bethlehem of
the Galilee not far from Nazareth he
says three key findings prove this is
the real birthplace of Jesus
this is the Bethlehem because Justinian
in the 6th Century built a wall around
Bethlehem and there is no wall in the
other wetland
a nearby tomb he says shows the Jews had
settled in this area during that period
and he points towards Jerusalem we know
that Jesus was born as a Jew leave as a
Jew and died as a Jew
so there should be community living in
the site where he was born and there is
no traces archaeological traces of
inhabitants in the Roman period in the
other Bethlehem
plus the remnants of a big and important
church he believes are proof this
Bethlehem was once an important place
for Christians his thesis though hasn't
gained much traction
these are the remains of the here in the
traditional Bethlehem in the occupied
West Bank there's more at stake than
historical truth or where exactly Mary
Joseph and baby Jesus found refuge for
centuries this has been a place of
pilgrimage of Tourism and of course big
business but that's not what's important
to religious leaders here
it's not only by the buildings it's not
only by uh maybe the the the things that
we're looking for exactly that this is
the right place but it's my belief and
by faith and this is the most important
thing
Ashley is committed to his theory and
vows to keep promoting it he claims it's
supported by facts and logic
But ultimately he agrees that for the
billion plus Christian faithful whether
there or here will all come down to a
matter of faith